Hey everyone, it's a long time no see right we were working a lot on the development and testing to make your life
And your education more entertaining and as well as
Easier for you to make some things
So yeah, let's start. We stopped last time. I think on deploying the moving average minor, right?
So I assume that you have
Running moving average minor and we will go next to the update and restart
Because a lot of changes were made inside the remote repository our main branch
we will need to
fetch all these changes and
Apply them. But first things first, I want to show you some Linux basics
So you
Sorry, so it's easier for you to navigate and understand what you're doing and how to navigate Linux really
So let's let's open my terminal window
Okay, so first things first I want to remove all this information is because it's a
Irrelevant, sorry, and I just need to press to enter clear command. Okay. Now terminal is clear
Let's start with the first command
Pwd it's print working directory. It shows you the path of
Where you are right now
let's
press
Let's enter the least command less. It's just printing the list of all the folders inside your
Working directory right now. So CD means change directory and let's go to the advanced ML testing
Okay. Now as you can see, I am inside this folder right now
And if I do this comment one more time, I can see that the bitbridge folder inside this
command here
Let's dive deeper into the bitbridge folder
One more time list command. Okay, I can see all the files from the bitbridge
folder right now
What is CD and double dot change directory double dot?
It's just you goes up to the one level, right? So now if we
list command we can see that I am one level above and
Let's go back to the bitbridge
Now I'm inside the bitbridge folder and for example if I press
Print working directory command, I can see the path. Where am I right now?
Okay, let's clear it up
What's next next is nano
So nano is this command opens the basic Linux text editor
So let's make some edits into the configuration file model prams.yaml
this is the main file you will work with and
Okay, I can scroll up I can scroll down and I can make all the changes here
So for example, let's change false
Let's put it through here
I
Need to press ctrl o to save this file. It asks us do we want to change the name of the file?
I don't want to change anything. So I just press enter and
Press ctrl x to close it up
Yeah, how I'm how I do
this so I just press arrow up or arrow down and
We're using this flow I can find the previous commands that was exit you executed in this terminal
Okay
Okay, control R. I can find the
Command that also was previously executed. For example, I want to activate the virtual environment and I need to run that
So you see I put just saw source and it found me the source
To wait virtual environment command that I run some some time in the bus. So I keep enter and
this command was executed and
Okay, let me show you one last thing how to scroll inside tmux session. So I assume you have run in minor
tmux attach
terminal
and as you can see here my minor is running, but if I try to
scroll it's
It doesn't allow me to do so but I can still do it. So we need to press ctrl B and
this
This thing I don't remember the name sorry
So it's control B and this sign and when you see on top
Right corner the yellow numbers. It means that you entered the navigation mode and here I can use
my mouse or I can use my
arrows to scroll up
Right. I can scroll down and
to quit this
Inevigation mode I need just press
Q press Q and my tmux session continue to work without me. Okay, I will stop here and
In next recording I will explain you
how to update your
Repository on the code base and fetch all the most recent changes. Thank you